the me2 campaign is giving a voice to
many women who say they've experienced
sexual harassment and abuse Alex Wagner
met with five women all leaders in their
own fields who say they are now speaking
out to help others Alex good morning
such an important conversation to have
for all of us such an important
conversation to have and to hear the
group we spoke with on Friday included
Jennifer Hyman co-founder and CEO of
Rent the Runway
Sally Krawczyk who before founding the
financial firm L vest was the CFO of
Citigroup Jane Rosenthal co-founder of
the Tribeca Film Festival and CEO of
Tribeca enterprises Elaine welter Roth
editor-in-chief at Teen Vogue and
Jessica Howard a three-time national
rhythmic gymnastics champion
Howard along with several teammates
accused her former team dr. Larry Nasser
of sexual assault while she was
competing all of these women shared
their experiences and offered insight on
how they hope to help more women as they
continue coming forward when I started
work on Wall Street
one day leaning over a desk to work on a
spreadsheet and turning around and there
was a guy behind me pretending to
perform a sex act on me with all the
other guys watching and all the other
guys laughing and this sense of
incredible shame I felt ashamed
absolutely and how could I've leaned
over the desk like that there's a
problem in that we're kind of
acculturated from the time were growing
up if this locker room talk starts in
high school with men thinking it's okay
to over-sexualize women like what did we
think was going to happen 30 or 40 years
later when they get into the boardroom
you think about incidents over the last
year with Harvey Weinstein and Roger
Ailes and Bill O'Reilly these are
companies where not just those
individuals were extremely powerful but
everyone who runs that company in any
position of power is a man look if you
had women on the boards in those
companies you would not have had the
kind of payouts there's no way the
majority of the cases even that have
come out in some ways there are gray
areas it's very rare ly black and white
you know I think there is this
problematic definition of rape as
something that happens in a dark alley
by a scary drunkard
stranger but the reality is that only 8%
of women are raped by strangers Jessica
I want to get you in here did you know
what was happening to you was wrong and
did you feel like there was someone at
the Olympics committee in management
somewhere on the team that you could go
talk to to help stop this behavior you
know I didn't and I was in a position
where I had to just trust this man
when news about dr. nasir started coming
out I realized I wasn't the only one and
more than 140 women have now come
forward and USA Gymnastics has done
nothing and I really believe that the
entire board needs to resign and there
have been changes at Fox there have been
changes at The Weinstein Company and USA
Gymnastics is just going on with
business as usual and it's it's hurtful
to me as a victim while we have victims
or survivors coming forward and saying
me too we need men to say I did that
you mean even men to step forward and to
see themselves in these stories I think
that there are a lot of men that are in
shock as to what they believe normal
behavior was harvey is an extreme case
that is a sexual predator and for
somebody to say I grew up in a sexually
promiscuous time is is bull especially
for somebody who is in media and always
looks to be at the foreground of culture
and also politics
we're different ages but we all know
about Anita Hill we know about Bill
Clinton we know Bill Bill Cosby
what makes this moment different the
proliferation of social media and media
outlets because back in the day if I had
wanted to say something what was I going
to do what's different about this moment
is we have a way to express our voices
what's also different about this moment
is women are rallying or
each other I don't know who said it but
Pandora's box is opened and Pandora is
pissed we have to ban together and now
our foot is firmly in the door now what
do we do okay
certain things happened then but this is
now what do I do and what do I say to my
daughters what do you say to your
readers do you think that young women
the readers of Teen Vogue are more
forthright about what's happening to
them in their bodies than older women
yes yes absolutely but I think one thing
I want to kind of put forward into this
conversation is that it happens to
strong powerful women too and so I think
this met it's important this messaging
about you know we need more women in
these leadership positions we need more
women on boards but it might still
happen to you I spoke up because I was
sexually harassed after already raising
over a hundred million dollars for my
company after having a successful
company and after I refused this
investor sexual advantage advances he
called my board members and told them I
was being unresponsive and should likely
be fired so he tried to come after my
career when I rejected him
what was your reaction to that I decided
that the reaction had to be a hundred
percent transparency so the second I
heard that that happened I went to my
board and I showed the text messages
that I had received and shared the
experience that I had had and honestly
my board members were shocked and we
decided as a board to take immediate
action together for me as a woman who's
dealt with some degree of it and funnily
enough I actually saw the person that
I've had an encounter with on the red
carpet walking into the glamour Woman of
the Year awards and in that moment I an
empowered woman a boss someone leading
the resistance for this generation
I felt conflicted I haven't addressed it
with this person I'm still wrestling
with it how many other women feel that
way how many other women who are
standing up and retweeting are still
traumatized and still trying to unpack
happened we talked about what happens
next
and we talked about that in the context
of people outside immediate victimhood
but what happens next for victims how do
you feel since these allegations have
been made public I've just come around
to the anger I really really struggle
and I don't know if it's ever going to
go away and I think that's an important
thing for people understand that this
doesn't just dissipate the moment you
speak up it's almost the moment that you
speak up that you can actually start to
process do you think that you can get to
a point where this isn't the thing that
you think defines you I hope so I really
do you know yeah and I seeing you guys
and just listening to everything that
you've been talking about it it almost
makes me want to cry
because I know that we can do what we
need to do to make sure this never
happens again so that not one person has
to come up and say you know me too
and I am just very empowered by
listening to you guys according to
multiple reports Jessica Howard's former
team dr. Larry Nasser is expected to
plead guilty to first degree criminal
sexual conduct charges in a Michigan
Court tomorrow
in a statement to CBS this morning USA
Gymnastics said our athletes are our
priority and we are committed to
promoting an environment of empowerment
that encourages speaking up especially
on difficult topics like abuse Jessica
certainly put them on notice I thought
she married a very good point and raised
some very troubling allegations about
them but I hope that this is more than
just a moment of we talk about it and
then it goes away that we get used to a
new normal we've all had experiences
where somebody does something you go
well that was bad but it wasn't that bad
and now we have to we have to face the
fact that it's all bad yeah varying
degrees but it's all bad and I think it
this moment is one of catharsis and
healing but there is the question when
do the men sit down at the table with us
because this is a conversation that
needs to happen with both genders
I said earlier you know it's systematic
and it's pervasive yeah and at what it
does is it cripples women's confidence
and it cripples their ability to succeed
and I think you have to understand that
and management has to understand that
not just say we're going to create a
safe work environment you actually
create that environment
these are shattering experiences we need
to make sure people are whole and zero
tolerance to norms irritants very
important but I thought Jane Rosenthal
had one of the best lines and arose
boxes open and Pandora is pissed and Ora
is pissed she is she's very pissed it
was a good idea to do that it's great
then we should say that was scheduled
weeks ago before that we are now
unfortunately part of this conversation
it is something Hannah was set up it's
yes set up for weeks that's right came
to fruition on Friday it's good timing
to be having this conversation
thank you very much Alex think